quoi qu'il vous soit arrivé
vous avez des cadeaux maintenant tout casse le
vainqueur j'ai hâte de voir ce que vous
concourez
dans le monde des uns et des zéros vous êtes
ces boîtes vont entrer en vous et trouver
vos faiblesses et vos peurs
prendre votre place parmi les courageux  ceux que
je ne suis pas brisé et je ne suis pas seul,
vous pouvez tourner le dos au monde
pour toujours
au-dessus ou au-dessous de milliers d'années depuis que
notre peuple a parlé
le premier-né de la reine et du sang bien-aimés
j'ai besoin de guerriers
vous ne pouvez pas avoir peur le temps a  viens
prendre le privé de ta mère c'est une
mauvaise idée de
combattre le diable dans son armée tu sais que
le monde entier pleure
un symbole
espérons que tu n'es pas trop tard c'est comme
s'ils en avaient peur mon fils
il est temps que je fasse un  promesse sur sa grâce
sans lui
[Musique]
ils voulaient que je revienne pour une raison
j'ai besoin de savoir pourquoi
tu